[Music]
growing up is tough and two local
organizations are stepping in to help
with our city's young men and women and
to join us more is to tell us more is
paul krakowicz the nevada region
president of intermouth and health
intermountain healthcare and liz
ortenberger the ceo of safeness welcome
you two thank you so much for joining us
thank you for having us liz i was just
talking to you off the air about this
these are two great programs really
helping our young adults
turn into really
big important members of this community
tell us a little bit about the program
absolutely so both programs are designed
to help high school athletes both male
and female navigate leadership and their
responsibilities because we know a
couple of things we know that 95 percent
of c-suite executives were athletes oh
interesting right and we know that
athletics can that relationship that
athletes have with their coaches is one
of the most important and dynamic
relationships they have as young people
so if we can help elevate that space by
talking about the things around healthy
relationships and what affect us growing
up and why it's inappropriate to say you
throw like a girl or to body shame in
the locker room we can elevate that
space for everybody so this one of the
programs is coaching boys into men and
then the other is athletes as leaders
yes tell us about the difference between
the two so coaching boys into men is
that as the title says is is really the
the boy version or the young athlete
version for the males and the athletes
as leaders is the girl a portion of the
program so both programs have the same
end result which is elevating athletes
with all of the right information that
they need to navigate their world what a
great great idea paul tell us a little
bit about intermountain healthcare's
role in these programs so as a
not-for-profit we look for where we can
have an impact in the community and
really around a chief health need we
realize that domestic violence was a big
issue
coaching boys into men and athletes as
leaders are both naturally recognizing
they use evidence-based care to do this
and finding a partnership with safe nest
was just kind of a perfect blend for us
to be able to bring together into the
community and what have you guys seen as
you work with these kids how how they've
grown what are how rewarding must that
be so absolutely so actually democracy
prep which is one of the schools that
we're heavily involved with had an
incident where a football player cat
called at a girl
and her parents actually called the
school and complained and the coach
who's trained in this program said
normally i would have not really known
how to navigate this but because of this
program i knew the conversation i needed
to have in my locker room and i knew how
to help my young men navigate this world
tell us how people can get involved how
do people
help out with this program absolutely so
if you are at a charter school you can
call safe nest you can call our main
line and get information or go to
safeness.org and request us to come out
to your school if you're in clark county
school district we need you to be asking
your administrators to get this program
active so that we can come to your
schools and implement we have lots of
football coaches who want this program
but we haven't been able to get ccsd to
approve it quite yet and that is so
important paul thank you and
intermountain healthcare for being a
part of these just a great initiative
and thank you for sponsoring this
segment for more information about
safeness visit safeness.org